c'est une livraison inusité qui a lieu
au centre d'hémodialyse de l'hôpital
charles lemoyne un don de 400 plants de
fines herbes qu'olivier dieccte va
ensuite distribué dans une dizaine de
petits commerces ont dit que 9 personnes
sur 10 qui est en faveur du don
d'organes mais qui est seulement quatre
personnes sur dix qui ont signifié leur
volonté à près de 800 patients sur la
liste d'attentes en attente d'un organe
qui avec le vieillissement de la
population c'est sûr que cette demande
lovers est croissante
donc on doit continuer à sensibiliser
ses de la terre à la table la table
d'opération bon que moi j'appelle ça de
l'agriculture sociale quelques dizaines
de plants arrive au café pistache à
l'intention des clients
je suis là pour le dr touché par le
geste de son ami qui a donné un rein à
son conjoint en octobre dernier
catherine lefebvre avait réservé un coin
de serre pour produire gratuitement les
fines herbes
oui on se connaît depuis l'enfance on
est allé on a fréquenté les mêmes écoles
stéphane à ses yeux de voir une greffe
de rein sur cinq au québec provient d'un
donneur vivant
sachant que la maladie de son conjoint
ferait flanché ses reins valérie leclerc
s'y préparait la dialyse s'en vient
faudra faire telle ou telle étape est
plus belle le don d'organes vivants et
on l'a abordée tout de suite parce que
moi je l'abordé tout de moi même pas
trop d'accord au début les douze
interventions simultanées se sont bien
déroulées comme avoir ressuscité fines
herbes les plantes représentent la vie
dont une belle analogie avec la
renaissance avec la transplantation
rénale et les organes avec les fines
herbes viennent des photos de famille
comme celle de charles étienne carrière
qui a reçu le rein de son père en 2011
et qui est lui même papa maintenant ce
que je vois c'est que par non il ne
serait pas là serait pas dire c'est
impensable à 20 heures de show l'ancien
gamin quand même 60 et 3 ans aujourd'hui
elle sort soit 100 points que du tout
les médecins les ré provenant de
donneurs vivants fonctionne deux fois
plus longtemps soit 20 ans au lieu de
dix le résultat était délicieux liam et
un autre enfant arrivera très bientôt
je suis témoin de ces petits miracles et
l'ogre mon but c'est juste de raconter
ses histoires lopssi j'espère que ça va
venir toucher les gens pis né à des
changements ici anne louise despatie
radio canada saint lambert
alors petit rappel de base comment faire
on sait notre carte landes où notre
carte d'assurance maladie sur le colin
qui vient avec une fois que colin eni
c'est comme ça notre signature et là ça
sauve des vies
c'est simple et ce qui est important et
une toux ceux qui s'occupent de ces
choses là nous le répète il faut aviser
aussi nos proches en cas de si c'est pas
classe le connaît plus la peau claire
bref on signe pour na vi nos proches
voilà